معنى الامن بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الياس حنا اذا انعكاسات
وتداعيات محتمله لهذه الخطوه الامريكيه
تقلق الجانب الاسرائيلي كيف نفهم الموقف
السيد اليسحاب
ازدهار اسرائيل تعتبر ان هذه المخازن هي
ضمانه لها لانها قد تغرف منها في حال
الازمات التي تسببت بها في المحيط بالعام
2006 سميح لها باستخدام او باستعمال مخزون
من هذه الاخيره حتى في حربها على غزه وعلى
حماس بالعام 2014 فاذا هذا شق اساسي يتعلق
باللوجاسيات في السيناري سيء الاسرائيليين
اما البعد الاخر والبعد ان تكون اسرائيل
مشاركه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم
في اوكرانيا ضد روسيا كي لا تنعكس على
استراتيجيه همم اسرائيل في همم يعني في
سوريا هذه السياسه منذ عام 1973 جدد ابن
عام 1980 كانت بالاليات في اسرائيل
وانتقلت بالعام 2000 الى الذخيره وما شابه
طب لماذا تلجا الولايات المتحده الى
مخزونها في اسرائيل من هذه الذخيره على ما
يدل ذلك
[موسيقى]
حسن المصروف الشهري للقوات او للمدفعيه
لانه اصبحت الحرب حرب مدفعيه في اوكرانيا
في ظل الثبات على ال ال ال ال الجزئي على
الحدود
تستهلك اوكرانيا 90,000 قذيفه شهريا هذا
هو ضعف ما يمكن للمعامل الامريكيه
والاوروبيه مجتمعه ان تعوض عنه فذهبت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى مخزون
اصلا موجود ان كان في اسرائيل او حتى في
كوريا الشماليه في كوريا الشماليه اتمنى
عسكريه ان ترسل هذه الذخائر وعليها علامه
كوريا
فئه الف قذيفه كره الجنوبيه نعم فتم شراء
منها 100,000 قذيفه ترسل الى اوكرانيا
والذخيره الجنوبيه الكوريه الجنوبيه تعود
المخزون للقوات الامري
سيد اللي يسالها تعتقد ان هناك رسائل
امريكيه مراد ايصالها من خلال هذه الخطوه
تحديدا للطرف الروسي بعد يعني دخول موضوع
المخزون في اسرائيل على الخط
ازدهار الرسائل الروسيه يوميا موجوده
نتحدث عن المدرعات البرادلي ونتحدث عن
باتريوت من بريطانيا
من المانيا ومن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
ودبابات مقاتله تشالنجر
بريطانيا وحتى قد تعطل هذه كلها رسائل
ولكن اليوم المعركه المعركه مدفعيه ويجب
ان يكون هناك مخزون لدى همم بالطبع هي
رساله
هنا يطرح سؤال يعني ايضا بديهي يعني اذا
كانت اوكرانيا مع كل هذا الدعم الغربي
بحرب المدفعيه هذه 90,000 همم
قذيفه مدفعيه همم تشعر بالنقص طيب ما حال
همم روسيا لماذا روسيا لا تش في هذا النقص
وهي الطرف الاخر بالحرب
حسن في معركه الدمباز 60,000 قذيفه يوميا
كانت تستعمل على سبيريدوناتس وليزيانسك
هذا الامر ادى الى استهلاك الكثير من
المخزون الروسي من هنا تم الحديث او
الاخبار عن طريق استيراد قذائف مدفعيه من
كوريا الشماليه يعني كوريا الشماليه كوريا
الجنوبيه مشتركتين بالحرب بطريقه غير
مباشره اليوم بعد هذه المرحله ساعه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى تحسين
الاستهلاك عبر قذائف ذكيه عبر الهايمارس
وعبر الاحداثيات الدقيقه كي لا يكون هناك
استهلال كثير استهلاك كثير للمدفعيه خاصه
من صنع غربي او امريكي ساعود الى ما يقلق
الجانب الاسرائيلي من وراء هذه الخطوه هل
يمكن ان تضحي فعلا اسرائيل
بعلاقاتها مع همم مع روسيا تحديدا
اسرائيل الحليف الاستراتيجي البعيد المدى
الكبير ولا يمكن الاستغناء عنه هو
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الامور
الظرفيه هي ما توفر من يهود روس في الداخل
الاسرائيلي ويؤثرون بطريقه ما
والاستراتيجيه المعتمده داخل سوريا لا
تريد اسرائيل ان تعقد روسيا عملياتها داخل
اسرائيل داخل روسيا سوريا ولكن تقول هناك
اقوال داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي تقول
ان هذه القذائف هي لملك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهي حره ان تفعل بها ما تشاء
ولكن دائما القلق الاسرائيلي هو من سوريا
وشمال سوريا شمال اسرائيل او جنوب لبنان
همم
وفي هذا المجال
هل
يتوقع من وجهه نظرك ان ياخذ الجانب الروسي
بهذا التبرير وبالتالي يبقي على قواعد
الاشتباك او قواعد العمل المعمول بها في
سوريا كما هي حتى الان
الامر حسن يتعلق بالقدره الروسيه نحن نعرف
ان روسيه بحاجه الى العسكر بحاجه الى
الصواريخ ارض جو اخذت الاس 3 الى اوكرانيا
سحبت الكثير من العسكر وبدات الساحه
السوريه وكانها ساحه ليست بالاهميه القصوى
التي كانت قبل حرب اوكرانيا يوم حرب
اوكرانيا هي اساسيه ومن هنا القدره على
فتح عده الجبهات هنا نفس الوقت هذا امر
غير مستحب المعنى العسكري والمعنى
الاستراتي شكرا جزيلا لك من بيروت الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي الياسحنا شكرا جزيلا
لك